ا
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد
لله والصلاه والسلام على رسول
الله وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين واشهد ان لا
اله الا
الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه
اجمعين اما
بعدده
ف ما زال الكلام
موصول في باب وفصل عظيم من كتاب زاد
المعاد
للحافظ المحدث شيخ الاسلام شمس الدين بن
القيم رح رحمه الله
تعالى وهذا الباب في مراتب
الدعوه ومراتب تشريع القتال
ومراتب
الناس ومراتب معامله
الناس المقاتلين له عليه الصلاه
والسلام وقد ذكر لنا المؤلف رحمه الله
تعالى
ان مراتب الكفار الذين رفضوا الدخول في
الاسلام او لم يقبلوه
باطنا هم اربعه
اصناف الاول المقاتل الذين هم ا
بارزوا دعوه الاسلام بالقتال
الظاهر ولم يبايعوا ولم يهادن النبي صلى
الله عليه
وسلم الثاني هو معاهد
والمعاهد الذي بينه
وبين
قومه والنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم عهد
وذمه فريق ثالث هم
الذميون الذين يؤدون الجزيه عن يد وهم
صاغرون ولا يقاتلون النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم واصحابه ولا
يظهرون العداوه له ولا لاصحابه
والمسلمين والفريق الرابع جماعه بين بين
وقد وصفهم النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم بق
بقوله فيما معناه مثل المنافق مثل
الشاه الشاه التي تكون
بين غمين فهي تاره الى ال هذه وتاره الى
هذه يعني هذه هذا ال هذه القطعه من الغنم
وتاره الى هذه القطعه من الغنم والله
سبحانه وتعالى وصفهم فقال
مذبذبين بين ذلك لا الى هؤلاء ولا الى
هؤلاء ووصفهم الله تعالى بانهم
منافقون
والنفاق هذه ظاهره انتشرت
بعد غزوه
بدر لان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم انتصر
انتصارا
عظيما على عدوه ولم يظن احد ذلك من
العرب فلما انتصر واقام في ميدان
القتال
ثلاثا ثم عاد هابته
العرب ودخل اقوام ايه مسلمين بايعوه ومنهم
المنافقون ارادوا ان يضمنوا
مصالحهم ارادوا ان يضمنوا
مصالحهم ولكن لا يدخلون في
الاسلام دخولا
حقيقيا يعني بظاهر القول اذا جاءك
المنافقون قالوا نشهد انك لرسول الله
والله يعلم ان انك لرسوله والله يشهد ان
المنافقين
لكاذبون ليسوا كاذبين بما قالوا كاذبين
بانهم لا يشهدون اي لا يعتقدون باطنا ما
يتفوهون به والله تعالى يقول يقولون
بالسنتهم ما ليس في قلوبهم والله تعالى
وصفهم
باوصاف
خطيره عظيمه
وجعل مثوى المنافق في الدرك الاسفل من
النار
لانهم لا الى هؤلاء ولا الى
هؤلاء وادوا النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
والمؤمنين اذاء
عظيما والله سبحانه
وتعالى صدر كتابه العظيم باوصاف
للمنافقين فقال جل وعلا
ومن الناس من يقول امنا بالله وباليوم
الاخر وما هم
بمؤمنين يخادعون الله والذين امنوا وما
يخدعون الا انفسهم وما
يشعرون في قلوبهم مرض فزادهم الله مرضا
ولهم عذاب اليم بما كانوا
يكذبون وفي قراءه سبعيه بما كان
يكذبون فهم يكذبون في قولهم امنا
ويكذبون رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
يقول تعالى واذا قيل لهم لا تفسدوا في
الارض قالوا انما نحن مصلحون الا انهم هم
المفسدون ولكن لا
يشعرون واذا قيل لهم امنوا كما امن الناس
الناس يعني اصحاب النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم امنوا فامنوا كايمان قالوا انؤمن كما
امن السفهاء لم يقولوا هذا
للمسلمين ظاهرا وانما يستهزئون في قلوبهم
هؤلاء سفهاء جماعه سفهاء ولا نؤمن ك
ايمانهم
ويستحقون وهذه من اوصاف المنافقين
يحقرون
المؤمنين يستحقر رسول الله
واتباعه صلى الله عليه
وسلم الا انهم هم السفهاء ولكن لا يشع
ولكن لا
يعلمون واذا لقوا الذين امنوا قالوا
امنا كيف هذا اذا التقوا مع المؤمنين اذا
جاؤوا الى المسجد اذا التقوا
معاهم قالوا يعني بافعالهم وباق لهم
وبيئاتهم يقومون يصلون ويخشع وينفقون و
قالوا امنا واذا خلوا الى
شياطينهم الى بعض
وخلوا اي الى الى شياطينهم من رؤساء
الكفار من اليهود الذين كانوا يزونه على
المؤمنين قالوا انا معكم انما نحن
مستهزئون الله يستهزئ بهم ويمدهم في
طغيانهم
يعمهون يبقون في التيه
حائرين اولئك الذين اشتروا الضلاله بالهدى
فما ربحت تجارتهم وما كانوا
مهتدين هؤلاء اذوا النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم ما
ايذاء والله سبحانه وتعالى وصفهم
بانهم يؤذون الله
ورسوله
وهؤلاء شرهم خطير جدا على
المؤمنين ولا يزال تبقى منهم باقيه الى
قرب
الساعه في مارز الايمان
في معقل الايمان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
يقول ان الايمان ليارز الى
المدينه كما
تارز الحيه الى
جحرها
يعني الايمان لا يزال بالمدينه الى قيام
الساعه الى ان لا يبقى احد من المؤمنين
ولكن مع ذلك يبقى المنافقون في في المدينه
تاتي زلازل ثلاثه كما اخبر النبي صلى الله
عليه
وسلم
ف ينصدع من المدينه كل
منافق حتى لا يبقى في المدينه
الا صافي المؤمنين وهذا قرب الساعه هذا في
اخر
الزمان وهذه ظاهره مهمه جدا ان نفهم
لماذا لان بعض الناس يتصور هؤلاء
المنافقين عبد الله بن ابي بن سلول
وجماعته تصورون
وكانهم وحوش لهم
انياب وهم في الحقيقه
اي هم من ب من بني
جلدتنا
ويتكلمون
بلغتنا ولساننا
ويحفظون من كتاب الله ومن سنه رسوله صلى
الله عليه
وسلم وبعضهم عنده
الشهادات وبعضهم عنده الجبه وعنده
العمامه
و عنده
التزكيات والى غير ذلك يقول رسول الله صلى
الله عليه
وسلم اخوف ما اخاف على امتي
منافقا عليم
اللسان المنافق عالم اللسان يسحر الناس
يضل الناس ولا تزل
تزال تجد اثار
و
ذريه عبد الله بن ابي بن سل وابن سلول
والمنافقين الى يوم الناس هذا يظهرون على
الشاشات ويتكلمون بلسان العلم ويشككون
المسلمين في
دينهم يشككون المسلمين في كتبهم في
علمائهم في
عقائدهم يشوشون عليهم ياتون بكل ما بكل
منكر وغريب وشاذ من الاقوال
والافعال
و يقدمون هذه الخبائث الى
المسلمين والنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
يخبرنا
ويامر ان نرفض هذه الدعوه وانا نقبل في
اخر الزمان الا ما
نعرف يقول عليه الصلاه والسلام كما في
السنن من حديث عبد الله بن عمرو بن
العاص
يقول
اذا رايت الناس مرج
عهودهم وخفت
امانات وكانوا هكذا وشبك بين
اصابعه ايش يعني وخفت امانات وكانوا
هكذا كان في زمن الرسول صلى الله عليه
وسلم في زمن
الفرقان هؤلاء مؤمنون
وهؤلاء غير
مؤمنين لكن لا يزال الناس يقتربون
يتنازلون عن دينهم وعن الحق حتى يكونوا
هكذا لا تستطيع ان تميز اهل الحق من اهل
الباطل ولا المسلم من غير المسلم ولا
المؤمن من المنافق وكانوا هكذا فقام اليه
عبد الله بن عمرو بن العاص رضي الله عنهما
وقال يا رسول الله فما تامرني حين
ذاك قال امسك عليك لسانك
والزم
بيتك وخذ ما تعرف ودع ما تنكر وعليك بخاصه
امر نفسك ودعك امر
العوام بعض الناس يرى انه لا بد ان يكون
مشاركا
في هذه الاجواء
التي تبقي وتترك وتذر كثيرا من الحلماء
حياره
هذه ازمنه يكثر فيها الكذب ويكثر فيها
الخيانه الخيانه العلميه والخيانه
الدينيه وخيانه الامراء لدولهم وخيانه
ولاه الامر
ل
شعوبهم هذه ازمنه يكثر فيها كل ما كان
غريبا
وطريف الامور العجيبه قصص عجيبه اقوال
عجيبه حتى تجد بعضهم يقول صحيح البخاري
ليس صحيحا فيه خرافات كثيره وكان شعار
الناس في هذا الزمن كيف ولما لا ياتيهم
امر من امر الله ورسوله صلى الله عليه
وسلم الا اعملوا في هذه النصوص بزعمهم
عقوله والحقيقه لا يعملون العقل في هذه
النصوص بل
يعملون
الهواى ما يهوون وما
يتصورونه فلا ياتيهم قول من قول الله ولا
قول رسوله الا قالوا كيف كيف هذا ولما هذا
وكيف ولما حتى ياتون
ب شعارات اي
ما سمعنا بها ولا العلماء في هذه الامه
المجيده يقولون هل هذه انت يا فلان تؤمن
بالاسلام النصي ولا الاسلام
المقصد يعني النظر الى مقاصد الاسلام ليس
الى نصوص
الاسلام وماذا يريد بهذا يريد ان يفرق بين
النص
والمقاصد وكانه يجعل النصوص تتصادم مع
المقاصد فعلى هذا
التفكير يهدم الانسان جميع الدين يستعملون
هذه الشعارات
الخبيثه معولا بايديهم لهدم
الدين لبنه
لبنه ويقولون باشياء عجيبه حتى ينكروا بع
بهم حتى ينكر بعضهم الوات الخمس يقولون بل
هي
صلاته الفجر ولاه عند
الرو ورون البخاري ومسلم وكرون
الحديث
بمجمله حت و الامر الى بعضهم انكر بعض
ايات القران قال هذه ايات مدسوسه
الى الى اين وفرغ القران من معانيه وجعلوا
القران لا يتكلم الا عن الفلك وعن النجوم
وعن السما
وعن الجسم الانسان وكانه كتاب طب ولا كتاب
جغرافيا ولا كتاب علم وفرغ القران من
معانيه وانكروا صفات
الله وانكروا شرائع الله
حتى ان بعضهم يخطئ الرسول صلى الله عليه
وسلم بل ان بعضهم يقول ان الرسول كفر كفرا
لحظيا اسال الله
العافيه يا ايها النبي لم تحرم ما احل
الله لك وتحريم الحلال
كفر على قوله نبرا الى الله من هؤلاء
وهذا ياتي به التنكه زي ما بقولوا عننا
ياتي بالتنكه ويطبل فيها وكل مذيع
وكل
كل كل قناه تتسابق اليه تعال عننا ضيف
مكرم الشيخ الدكتور العلامه الم عارف ايش
اقوال ما اطلقت على عمر ولا ابي بكر رضي
الله عنهما ثم ياخذ يهذي يهذي
ويقول ويقول ويقول
ويحدث البلبله بين
المسلمين ويفرق الناس ويعلم السفهاء
منا اشياء من من قديم
شنشنه الفرق
الضاله هؤلاء هم المنافقون لم
يزالوا ولن يزالوا الى قرب الساعه واكثر
من
يتبع
الدجال هم
المنافقون
ولذلك ينكرون خروج الدجال يقولوا ما في
دجال هذه خرافات من اهل الكتاب ما فيش
دجال ولا في دابه تتكلم ولا في هذه
الاشياء التي جاءت في السنن الدجال
والمهدي و ق ما ما في دجال ولا رجوع عيسى
بن مريم عيسى بن مريم صح يح ما صلب راح
تجوز ومات
عادي ياتوا باشياء والله ما يتجر عليها
احد من الصحابه ولا احد يخاف الله بل قد
جماعات من اليهود والنصارى لا يتجرؤون على
مثل هذه الاقوال وياتون بفتاوى شاذه
وغريبه وعجيبه ويحللون ما اراد الجمهور
على زعمهم ويحرمون
ما قال به صراحه رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم
ويحللون هؤلاء اخبر النبي صلى الله عليه
بخروجه هذه مساله مهمه مساله مهمه الا
نكون من الغافلين الله سبحانه وتعالى اطنب
الذكر اطنب في ذكر المنافقين وفي فضحهم
وعلاماتهم و طريقه
كذبهم ويخفون يندس بين
المسلمين ياتون بهذه الاشياء وفيهم الحقد
وفي قلوبهم السم على الاسلام
والمسلمين وان كان بعضهم يزعم انه مسلم
اذا قال هو مسلم قصده مسلم على كيفه على
خاطره الاسلام ما يريد هو الاسلام ليس كما
يتلقى عن العلماء ويضلل العلماء ويقيس
علماء الاسلام
بقساوه النصارى
واليهود ويجعلون تاريخ النصارى هو تاريخ
المسلمين هذه مساله خطيره جدا لابد للمسلم
ان يكون حذرا النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
حذر كما ذكر الامام مسلم في مقدمه صحيحه
عن ابن
مسعود يخرج اناس كذابون دجالون ياتونكم
بما لم تسمعوا انتم ولا اباؤكم فاياكم
واياهم هكذا يقول صلى الله عليه وسلم يوصي
امته هذه امه مجيده واذا نظرت في التاريخ
وجدت متى اطاعت هذه الامه علمائها وقدموا
القران
والسنه اعزهم الله ومتى انقلبوا على
علمائهم
واخروا وفرغ معاني القران والسنه نصوص
القران والسنه من معانيها اذ لهم الله ولا
بد لا بد عمر رضي الله عنه يقول نحن قومنا
عزنا الله
بالاسلام فمهما ابتغينا العز في غيره
اذلنا
الله
ويقول المغيره ابن شعبه
لما جاءه عامل كسره
واستحق والصحابه والمؤمنين لما ارسلهم عمر
رضي الله عنهم وجاء عامل كسر وقال ما انتم
شو شوال الشرذمه هي جايين تقاتلوا كسره
بمجده فقال له المغيره نحن قوم من
العرب كنا
نلبس الشعر
والوبر ونعبد الشجره والحجر ونمص النوى من
الجوع حتى بعث الله الينا رسو من انفسنا
نعرف اباه
وامه و اخبرنا رسولنا عن ربنا وامرنا
بقتال
واخبرنا انه من قتل منا دخل جنه لم يرى
مثلها
قط ومن عاش منا ملك
رقابكم وهكذا
كان
هؤلاء لم
يتقدموا بكيف
ولما ياتيهم الامر من امر الله او رسول
يقولون كيف كيف هذا لما
لماذا ان الله يامركم ان تذبحوا بقرا
قالوا تستهزئ
بنا هذا ليس شعار الصحابه شعار الصحابه
سمعنا
واطعنا قل صدق
الله فبقوله صدق الله وسمعنا واطعنا اتاهم
الله تعالى الملك في ايمانهم واتاهم النور
والحكمه في في يدهم الاخرى
وتوجههم وملكهم رقاب اهل
الارض ولما اصبح المسلمون يتعلمون من
الكفار شنشنه تعلمون من المنافقين منهم
حتى قال الامام احمد رحمه الله
تعالى ياتي على الناس زمان المؤمن فيهم
بينهم
كالجيفه
والمنافق حيث يشار اليه
بالاصابع قالوا كيف اصحاب
احمد كيف ذاك يا ابا عبد الله قال ان
المؤمن اذا راى امرا مما امر الله اذا راى
منكرا فانه لم يستطع ان يصبر حتى يقول
ويتكلم فهنالك يقول الناس فيه فضول هذول
متشددين هذول عندهم ج ثومه التحريم هذول
متخلفين هذول مش عارف هذه
الاقوال فيه فضول هذا ينكر علينا المنكر
يامرنا بالمعروف اصلا القران والسنه في
عقول الناس كان القران والسنه غير مفهوم
اصلا ليس
مفهوما القران والسنه غير مفهوم احنا نقرا
القران نعم لكن كل ايه فيها 20 معنى من
انت تقول المعنى اللي انا اختاره ولا
اخترع انه غلط مش عارفين اذا القران ليس
مبينا القران جاء وحير
الناس قال واذا راى
المنافق امرا
منكرا وضع يده على فيه يعني ما تكلم
فهنالك ييقول الناس خير الرجل نعم الرجل
ليس فيه فضول
هكذا يقول الامام احمد ان الاسلام بدا
غريبا وسيعود كما غريبا كما بدا فطوبى
الغرباء ابن القيم رحمه الله يقول
الغرباء بان
المسلمين غرباء بين غير
المسلمين
يقول
و اهل
التدين واهل العمل والعباده من المسلمين
غرباء بين
المفرطين واهل السنه غريبين بين جماعات
اهل البدع والضلال
والانحراف حتى ان البلد قد لا يكون فيه
الا رجلا واحدا ترى في وجهه سمه الايمان
ونور هذه مساله
خطيره وهذا كله من ارث
المنافقين حذرنا الله سبحانه وتعالى
ورسوله حتى
نحذرهم المعاد
الله عليه
وسلم ty
ال speaking about those who did not
enter isam
tyes the
first are
‏these
indiv those
c the prop صلى الله عليه
وسلم gru
الله سبحانه
وتى ty and those
are
tax a non in a musl state pays the in
order to as we men you know in
greata these are the
‏considered
cien and they are considered people that
have the protection of the muslims they
have access to the amenities of the
muslims in their state and they
contribute and whatever is
for the muslims is for them and whatever
is against them is
against this is in order to
facilitate an out
‏people who
wish not
islam facil out to them الله سبحانه
وتعالى لاكره
فيدين no
for
اسلام the fourth type is a group that
are incredibly
sck very
frightening people who are at their
essence
مقين
المنافقون الله سبحانه
وتعالى hit
however
trans great
why
وفا على وزن فعال
‏from word نفق نون والفا
والقاف in the deser they make these tun
like
chip have two entran
‏and if some tri to some predator tries
to come at them from this entrance they
will go the other entrance ver الله
سبحانه
وتالى مقين
[Silence]
‏exits are to say always
the نشهد انك لرسول
الله and
if the enemies are given any kind of
victory or momentary glory they will say
we helped you guys we were there with
you the whole time ‏their point is to be
with whoever the winner is and i know in
the time that we live that kind of
sounds a good strategy that is the
strategy of an
animal that is not the strategy of a
human being who has the heart of a human
being a human being what separates the
human being from the animals one of the
things that separates us is that we have
standards we have morals we have things
that we will die for
‏that's what makes us
human human being has
dig these individuals they have no
dignity they have
no their point is to survive just like
rats on a
ship them with the winner whoever that
is
‏whether
win
bann لا اله الا
الله
قران
destion
destion destion
‏saying they
believe holding the in
hearts looking down
and صلى الله عليه
وسم pass
agressive in their
ways for instance in the battle
of الله عليه وس
كان قادمين
على صل الله عل
وسلم الماء قليل فلا يسبقنا الى البئر احد
حديث عن
مسلم well
‏so no one is to come to the well before
us no one takes water before i get there
in order to make sure
that find بعض
المقين when he asked them didn't i say
no one is to come to this well and draw
from it before i
arve ما علنا
وهكذا
هجره يستهزئون بالمؤمنين يعظمون
الكفار صلى الله عليه وسلم
‏a disease that is normal is that
fest and rar has a cure what is that
disease
usually people normal human
beings if they treated kindly they
reciprocate this is actually one of the
six unanimous ways of
‏pypr الانسان ولقد كنا بني
ادم d
‏it does matter how good kind the
prophet عليه
وسلم the more kindness them the
more the more hat fed in
hearts صل الله عليه
وسلم الله سبحانه
وتالى س
‏that not only
refuse that his messenger had given them
of
weth but they are arr and they are angry
if they not given and if they are given
they even more angry
[Silence]
‏this indiv no matter what he does will
always be in the
red and this
tye this tye of
mal and wickedness in the heart
عل
وس عائشه رضي الله عنها accused of the
indecent of things his wies he
was عليه الصه
والسلام صل عليه وسم
محد صلى الله عليه و that h will
always spre out among ranks
muslims those who are fly hypocrites
mean that they disbelieve in allah the
last
‏in theirs and they mas as
believer or they have the traits of
hypocrisy and those who are very very
prone to lean and to be
apologetic with the hypocrites
and this will continue this strain of
disbelief will continue in the ranks of
صلى الله عليه وسلم tells that
those upon his ence
and those are to following him
are
المقون grou
المقون his
fit
very
appropriate next ان شاء الله تعال will
disc per after we have because ‏next ان
شاء الله تقل الله مننا
وكم ان شاء الله
next tra hrit as اليم رح اللهى انزاد
المعاد بدر اعلم صلى الله وسلم على نبينا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه